thank you suspicious bam uh how to alpha
male deleted video did he get
man he is quick he mean he not only did
he get it up he got it up
boom suspicious band by the way guys i'm
gonna i'm gonna plug him because he's
made
of quite a few parodies and stuff for
our show can we please can i please
subscribe to these people sure
it says the tiny mouth vigilante talks
about how he made a baby factory on
salmon
what a what an [ __ ] thank you
suspicious
very cool all right let's hear it out
how to alpha male
coming at you with yet again another
video
my videos are helpful interesting
entertaining
or you just like watching my excited fat
mouth talk
go ahead and hit that like comment share
and subscribe button i like how his
sunglasses
got into this yeah the eye sleeve so
they're like
that happens in some of his videos like
such an idiot this guy is a fool
this video is going to be called
the moment i knew i wanted to be a man
something along those lines the title
might change a little bit
but it's basically the moment i knew i
wanted to be a man
all right i'm right out for me i went
over to a friend's house one day and he
uh he pirated a copy
of the sims 3. i was playing it on his
computer i
uh had a profile myself and uh
i had this little character and uh what
i did was i turned
um i i i i made it so i turned his
charisma
all the way up in his charm all the way
up
and uh which i wish i could do in real
life and then i had him start writing
so there is a lot of fake laughing in
this you're gonna love it
in novels and so he was writing
masterpiece after masterpiece after
masterpiece and he was pulling in like a
hundred thousand dollars a week right so
he was
he was pretty well off he was getting it
done and um
this guy this character i made so
uh i put i put cheats on right why are
you laughing
honestly no seriously why is he laughing
though because even he knows how cringe
the story is
the only thing the only way you could
tell the story is by being like
so check it out just as like a goof
right
it's like in the deep down he's like god
i wish cheat codes were real
he keeps hitting tilde but nothing
happens i wish i could hit f1 and open
up the console lots of commands
and give myself max i wish i could type
in a girlfriend command
anyway first off do lock picking first
it's way more useful
so i max holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] charisma i maxed it out i
absolutely shot it through the roof
and um so i shot his charisma through
the roof right
and uh so uh
there was this story's so boring he's
losing himself oh yeah he is
but trust me the story's worth it does a
good bail eat
there's this cheap where you can have
the where you can have
everybody the entire town uh
on your contacts list this so i cheated
animated so
i had the entire town on my contact list
this is gonna
this is really going to reflect poorly
on me
but um this is about to find out why he
deleted the video hey don't worry bud
i don't think that this is gonna be
there
whatever what i decided to do
is that in in the uh sims there was a
function where you could invite people
over
and uh you could have sex with them
right
why is that funny that's been in every
sims
this is
oh [ __ ] i don't know how he does it it
gets really hot in there really quick
so ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha
my character would invite women over
and just viciously
wacky this is like so this guy right had
to use cheat codes and then this guy
would get girls to come over his house
and have sex with him
can you believe that [ __ ] yeah i can
[ __ ] the character to [ __ ] the women
right
first off anybody that downloads like
nude mods for any game like
fallout or skyrim they should be put on
i don't believe in watch list but they
should be put on a federal watch list
right that's weird like they live out
their lives in skyrim and they need us
you need to they need to actually see an
erect penis in skyrim to be like
now i'm immersed and i came it's a
little weird it's weird right
it's always it's weird too i remember i
was freaked out when i went on uh
nexus mods and i was downloading fallout
4 mods
and i remember seeing like a lot of the
top mods
are like nudes and like yeah sexy making
a female companion sexy like why where
they had to put
it was so many that nexus mods has to
put a little switch on
where it's like not adult because if not
all the top and that's the creepy part
you would think the top ones would be
like lighting textures and like you know
making water look
cool or 4k graphics but if you put them
the adult thing on
all the top ones are just like realistic
titty bounce
nexus mods is just like vagina holes
nexus mods is just like
d live if you unclick the uh not safe
for work then suddenly everything
changes
at first i thought it was entertaining
whatever it was you know to have my
my character be such the world's
greatest player he was chad thundercock
to the extreme
this man thinks memes are like life also
which is also very cringy
and um so then i noticed that playing
the sims without nude stuff and it's
pretty cringy yeah of course
way better games way better yeah the
function where it was like
you could you could you could invite
women over and try for a baby
my buddy's wife used to play the sims
and she was addicted to it
to the point where we lived on the beach
in north carolina when i say on the
beach i mean literally ocean view
from the apartment and we would always
be like hey we're
you know we have some chinese food and
we're going to go surfing or we're going
to go to the beach and then we're going
to go fish we're going to do all this
touch be like i'm going to play the
theme and i just remember being like
okay you're playing a game where you do
dishes and you go
we're gonna go to the actual beach
where you can actually interact with
real people i'm gonna play the sims
[Music]
in the middle of the summer in north
carolina on the outer banks and you're
like there is a whole world of things
going on
outside it was a function where it was
like you could
you could you could invite women over
and try for a baby
so impregnate them right this
can reflects really bad on me no no no
don't worry
don't worry you're not you weren't
exactly killing it before this this is
actually what i expected
i'm being honest what ended up happening
is i was just like dude this is amazing
right
so what once i one you know inviting
some
dumb character over and just [ __ ]
them was um
it was whatever but as soon as the
impregnation concept i was like wow
right and
are you a psychopath that is like he's
on
weird right too much laughing not
nothing is funny
i feel like i'm watching a really bad
audition tape for the joker yeah
i i turned so jared leto's audition for
the joker stop
[ __ ] laughing like i don't
know i really want like i want if i were
in that room and he were telling this
story with that dumb mask on
i would slap those glasses off of his
face
and the and the laughing would stop and
he also wouldn't do anything
[Laughter]
smack and you see the glasses fly off
and then he just stops telling the story
and you're like no no keep telling the
story just
stop laughing for love of god
into a literal baby factory
i would just pick down the list of the
contacts
invite the girls over and they would
they
100 every single time
they left pregnant they would come in
they would walk in the door
not pregnant and they would leave
pregnant every
single time
and i remember distinctly that there was
this one woman who was supposed to be
married to this one rich guy
in the sims and um this isn't real dude
it's
this he's telling me four minutes but
remember i'm telling this like these are
real people
and again the title of this video was
how i knew i wanted to be an alpha male
that was the original title
i was [ __ ] around and i know and my
character knocked that
knocked that character up five times he
had five
kids with that woman
but that's not real life
the husband wasn't real yeah these
weren't real people it's a video game
that you were
using cheat codes in house there was
all five of my kids raised by this one
guy
and the girl i was like this is [ __ ]
up but this is amazing it was like
cocaine to my masculinity
it was it was insane but it's right not
horrible it was cocaine to his
masculinity this
is to loot this this level of delusion
cocaine to his masculinity but it's not
real
um like even if you played madden right
but you're playing against an opponent
and you wanted that you could be like yo
i was so pumped
like i whooped his [ __ ] ass in matt
and i was doing victory laps and i
played as the dolphins and i still beat
that
then you gotta like a good story this
guy used cheat codes
to make a little ai script do what it's
told and then and now he's like
telling the story like he's cool
this like i would have this i would have
one girl come over
knock her up have her sister come over
knock her up
have her mom come over knocked her up
and just
it would just be it was like a factory
it was like a baby-making factory
and i i just knocked up like every [ __ ]
i'm pretty sure before i was done that
every [ __ ] woman in the town
was was knocked up by my character
and by the by by the time
by the time i was done um i counted and
my character had 94 children
and um to the point the point is really
what is this stupid story
what's the point what is the point here
it is here we go the point is finally
what's the point
is that when i did that it's
it was like cocaine for my masculinity
and i realized that perhaps you know
raising uh raising a family in the
normal sense was not for me
just how much that scratched my
masculine niche
i was like that lifestyle or something
like that that's what i want to start
working towards that's what i want to
be so that
story just scratched my masculine itch
so much it was like
i i just realized that i want to be that
or i want to be something very much like
so playing sims 3 made you decide
that you just want to [ __ ] chicks bro
and i'll take care of the kids
very alpha male moves not alpha not
raising your kids isn't a very alpha
male move am i wrong here
no that i'm not saying i want to end up
with 94 children but uh
you know what i can't i can't deny the
the appeal
of the lifestyle that my character was
living i really want to watch this guy
talk to a girl
i'll pay to arrange it i don't even care
i need to get him and a girl in the same
room but would he have to take his mask
off
like that's the question would he would
he have to take his uh his mask off
leave the mask on who cares right this
is this is suspicious
hey hey it's your friend batman with the
mail coming at you with yet again
another video why did he change the
color of it my videos are helpful
interesting entertaining or you just
like watching my
fat mouth talk this video is going to be
called
the moment i knew i wanted to be a fat
mouth
man i i went over to a friend's house
one day
and i have sex with them
right so i had i had him all the way up
this guy this he was pretty well off he
was getting it done
because i was just like dude this is
amazing right
crazy chad thunder i guess we know
why suspicious spam had this full video
yes i think we
figured out why suspicious spam just
happened to have a whole copy of the sun
edited tape laying around
and the best part is since his face is
covered with a mask you could have say
whatever you want
and it syncs up it really is perfect
i turned keep 100
to just come over my fat mouth it was
like wow it was just
whoosh he absolutely shot it through the
roof
it was like this is amazing it was like
cocaine
but uh you know what i can't i can't
deny the
car the [ __ ]
all right here's the link by the way if
you guys want to subscribe to suspicious
bam
that was that was [ __ ] great